how should you behave on Facebook and
how should you behave on Twitter I think
Twitter drives me a little bit crazy you
know I'm on it a fair bit I'm not sure
it's a good thing and I tend to
distribute things that are alarming
let's say in some sense maybe they are
alarming ideological or ideologically
they're disturbing and I was thinking
about that today in preparation for this
talk and I wasn't really sure that was
necessarily a good idea because there
are a lot of alarming things happening
all the time everywhere obviously and
now we can share all of them always all
the time and so that means that instead
of hearing about one alarming thing a
day you're hearing about like 500
alarming things a day and so then you
know what are you supposed to do about
that is that does that indicate the
state that there's a state of emergency
well you don't know because you don't
know how to calibrate the information so
I was thinking well maybe the right way
to behave on Twitter is only to forward
good things that are happening you know
because there's lots of good things that
are happening but I actually don't know
the answer to that I have no idea and I
don't think anybody else does either I
do know that there are studies with
regards to Facebook that show that the
more time that you spend on Facebook the
more depressed you are and that it looks
like it's a causal relationship rather
than just a correlational relationship
and it seems to have something to do
with the fact that Facebook is one of
those platforms where everybody puts up
an advertisement for their life right
it's like Here I am with my new
girlfriend in the Bahamas being happy
and Here I am an amount and being happy
and it's like it's not you like
miserable with a cover over your head
unable to get out of bed you don't you
don't you don't broadcast that you can
think well it means you're presenting
people with a falsely positive view of
your life and then they compare their
lives to it and they come up short and
you think well that's a kind of
deception but by the same token you
don't stop random strangers on the
street and tell them how miserable your
life is right they don't want to hear
about that they they want to see a
facade of normality in in in you know
just casual day-to-day interactions and
so part of pro-social behavior is only
to put what's at least you know
normative and good forward so it doesn't
matter I mean so I don't think that's
necessarily
deception but the mass consequence of
that is something that we don't
understand at all and so well so with
that sort of introduction I'm going to
kind of walk you through my experience
with social media and let's say the old
media for lack of a better word and I'll
try to give you a balance to count and
to tell you well and to see if I can
draw some conclusions about what's
happened